dozens of wealthy parents have been
indicted in a college admissions scandal
about 50 people total it includes some
famous actors and actresses like
Felicity Huffman and Lori Loughlin the
mom from Full House has been indicted
charges for the 50 people roughly 50
people include bribery and fraud all
meant to get their kids into good
colleges and universities presumably
better colleges and universities than
their grades intellect and
extracurricular activities would have
otherwise gotten them into big name
schools are involved here Yale Stanford
USC other schools and there were a few
different methods used sometimes it
involved paying college coaches
including to get them to say that their
kids are not only good at a sport that
maybe they play but even good at sports
that they don't play at all creating
staged pictures rowing for example and
getting a coach to say yeah this is a
great rower we should allow them to come
to the school which of course
circumvents the normal sort of academic
admission requirements another version
of the scam and other side of the scam
was paying either consultants or exam
administrators to sometimes let smarter
people take tests for their kids another
version of it was you would get
fraudulent documents to justify extra
time for test taking like on SATs on the
basis of a learning disability that
didn't really exist and then the proctor
of the test would be in on the scam and
sometimes they would be the ones
completing the tests for the students so
there are a bunch of different versions
of this and a bunch of different sides
to it but we're talking about really big
money here sometimes a total of more
than a million dollars per student could
be as cheap as $50,000 for a test score
could be as much as $200,000 for those
fake sports credentials that I mentioned
and this is criminal in some cases this
is horrible this I don't think you're
teaching your kids any good lessons here
but you know
that you are sort of teaching them
realistic ones which are that money and
connections can get people elite status
whether or not they've earned it and
that's actually a realistic life lesson
and in theory you could serve this
should be against this because this is
essentially a handout it's not as if the
students are achieving things based on
their own merits they just so happen to
have wealthy parents and you know this
is how wealth is able to stay in
families for generations we don't live
in a true meritocracy of the four
hundred richest Americans according to
Forbes 60% of them inherited their
wealth and it starts with this it starts
with parents getting theirs to their
kids into wealthy schools and then it
goes from there now let's be very clear
here what we're now talking about
indictments is over the line into
criminality but of course a system that
is so broken to begin with as is our
education system and our socio-economic
system it's obviously going to be ruined
by corruption and what I mean by that is
the following in this particular case we
have crimes dealing with front
businesses a guy named William singer
who was a sort of facilitating a bunch
of what was being done here and we could
spend an hour just talking about the
details of this illegal version of this
influence and and sort of elite family
and wealth
a vicious circle that exists but think
about how not surprising it is in the
context of the larger educational system
college sports okay
college sports are already rife with
corruption it's been like that for
decades some of it legal and some of it
illegal maybe corruption is not the
right term cronyism and the type of
stuff that we're talking about the
college cost infrastructure is
completely out of control and it is
reinforced and perpetuated in a vicious
cycle by the fact that it's easier and
easier to get student loans with which
you can pay schools more and more money
for room and board every single year
student lending in and of itself riddled
with predatory victimization of students
completely unsustainable in every way
and allowing students to go further and
further into debt in fields that will
eventually never really allow them to
pay off those loans because of wage
stagnation legacy admissions another
practice that just reinforces this
elitism that Pat is talking about and
then you get to where it starts to get
more borderline right so the use of
consultants to help families with advice
totally legal that also is an unequal
advantage many or probably most people
can't afford to pay college consultants
to help get them into college so then
you go from just advice about how your
essay should be written to someone who
actually sits with you and writes the
essay with you now we're talking about
cheating but is that illegal and it's
just a gray area sliding-scale
consider for example the golden boy
Jared Kushner what about donating to a
school and then your kids get in Jared
Kushner's father donated 2.5 million
dollars to Harvard right around the time
that Jared Kushner was applying to
Harvard and then Jared Kushner not
surprisingly got into Harvard what's the
difference the difference is we've
decided some of this stuff is criminal
and some of it is not and by the way you
think
you-you-you have some idea now why
Donald Trump doesn't want his grades or
SAT scores released I think this scandal
actually tells us a lot about that do we
believe that the Bush family is all
geniuses who on the basis of intellect
deserve to go to the schools that they
went to you be the judge so the the
message for me here is crime is a social
construction in the sense that society
decides what is considered criminal and
what isn't murder okay basically
everybody agrees that should be criminal
but then you get into stuff like
lobbying political donations influence
pendulum peddling of different kinds
bribery fraud College consultants etc
some of the stuff is over the line and
some of the stuff is not and some of the
actions in this College Admission
scandal cross the line into what society
has decided his criminality I get it's
not the same thing to donate a building
to a school versus to pay an
expert to write your kids admission
essay I get that it's not the same but
if you do a serious analysis of the
college system both things we would
expect to be going on in a system that's
designed the way our system is used and
both are ways to use money to get a kid
into a school that they might not
otherwise get into so there's a lot of
criticism to go around parents coaches
who accept the bribes consultants who
cross the line but it's a rigged system
some tactics are legal some tactics are
illegal but it's not a sustainable
system in any way and it allows the rich
to have special access to education
which gets them special access
privileged access access to positions of
authority and we continue to have the
same families dominating society it's
how the system works period what are you
teaching your kids when you do this even
if they don't know not really sure it's
not how I would live my life if I had
kids and I think a lot of people in our
audience probably share that point of
view